okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
oh god that's hot piping hot
super early
morning i'm picking up my sister from
the airport you'll probably see her on
the show tonight which is exciting okay
um but i had a little time so i thought
i'd make a video
and i want to talk about like games
and this came up because
have a couple friends that like
with guys they're really good at playing
it cool right and really good at like
like
not texting them first and like waiting
super long between texts
and i am out of the loop
i
i don't really like do that
like
how i put it
oh god oh no my phone's dropping don't
drop don't
because in my head
those games might work but like in my
head it's like if you play stupid games
you win stupid prizes
so
my strategy in dating maybe you guys can
tell me if this is wrong
as if i like a guy i act like i like him
i'm not afraid to text first i'm not
afraid to like
i don't ask him to hang out if i want to
hang out
and
i feel like if a guy actually likes you
it's not gonna freak him out and it's
not gonna like make him not interested
but
if a guy doesn't actually like you then
it's gonna freak him out
or like come on too strong or whatever
i'm not talking about like text like
being annoying like texting them all day
or whatever but like
i just don't have a problem like acting
like i like a guy
but then you hear like femininity
coaches talk and they'll be like sit
back let him like let him do all the
work but i'm just not
i've always been a go-getter if i like a
guy i act like i like him and sometimes
it gets me burned don't get me wrong
it's not like a perfect
process but
i don't know the
dating games and like the texting games
and all that stuff just is not for me
it's not
um but let me know if you think i should
try them
and let me know
um and don't forget to subscribe i don't
know this is my morning thought today